you've got to if you're if you're at all
creatively minded if you're not just
doing it for the money
like you said it becomes lifeless at a
certain point when you just the record
is on sk
you know repeat we both do things that
that we can
see ourselves in our work and we can see
ourselves getting better and building
something bigger
and a lot of people they don't realize
that is like
i gotta keep chasing these like i know a
lot of people who do this with they're
just
they have businesses and of course
there's products
and marketing that they don't pay as
much attention to that stuff but they
pay attention to
their p l statement at the end of the
month like okay all i want to do is
it's a competition it's like gambling
it's like yeah well i'm there
you can get addicted to wanting to make
that number bigger
every month or every year
yeah and it's uh the problem is
is that in a lot of situations you can
win
short term and lose long term and that's
what i see the sacrifice a lot
of companies make large companies and
small creators make so for example
to take my one real job so to speak was
i was as i said new new home sales
graduated
um with chemical engineering hated that
so i was like well let me do youtube and
on the side i got this job
and one of the things i hated is we'd
have these weekly sales meetings and
everything was about
sales that quarter and like even like
there was
big pushes like if we're gonna miss our
numbers that quarter it was the
obsession was not make more sales but
let's move a bunch of sales up
like let's sort of fudge the numbers to
make it seem like we're doing more sales
this quarter
we're hustling for this quarter
everything's about numbers now
but there's an immediate cost long term
because the sales this quarter is the
sales not
next quarter so it doesn't matter you're
just moving numbers around
but they were obsessed with that not
obsessed with how do we make the
experience better for our buyers how do
we
improve the product we're selling how do
we
make things better and probably 80
percent of the energy of the company
was all about now numbers and nothing
about
long-term happiness of the clients or
the customers
no okay no focus on that and so when i
look at creators
put this to youtube or you know sales or
any kind of these info
products when your focus is
just moving numbers around pushing
pencils taking
numbers from tomorrow and bringing them
to dead today
you're gonna lose long term because
you're not putting the effort into what
actually is bringing in the sales which
is the customer experience that's the
long-term sales generator is nothing to
do with
quarterly reports or anything like that
and so i find the problem is
is that most of the metrics we have
access to are
quality unrelated that's the problem
people are obsessed with watch time oh
man this says it's all a competition
like through rate this is whatever what
i'm saying is those quantitative numbers
are not necessarily linked to what's
going to get you the views
no definitely not and if anything they
drive down what's going to get
give you the most amount of views and to
for example to give you what joe rogan
has if you want what he has
then you can't look at you can't worry
about the numbers you can't worry about
your headlines
because that's just going to stifle the
the
how good your content is or the
integrity of your content and the
problem like going back to what you're
saying about companies is that
i think a problem with these companies
while they worry about all their monthly
sales reports and trying to
pack as many sales in or to hit a goal
for that month
is because you know they're competing
with a bunch of other businesses
that have extremely high overhead and
they want to beat those businesses to be
listed as the top 10 most profitable
businesses in
their their city or whatever that month
um instead of taking a breath
and being like okay how can we create
something
that is just better than everything else
you nailed it i mean it's hard to say it
better than that uh
yeah yeah absolutely and you're
incentivizing people so
one thing that i saw is the sales
managers were incentivized to focus on
the quarterly reports because that's
what they reported to
so their bosses were looking at that and
so they looked at that
and i'm sure those bosses were also
looking like so
in order to i mean now we're talking
about sort of management theory but like
i'm a big believer that incentives drive
everything it's part of the reason that
i
mock people who are in this world is
because i believe the incentives shift
when you get mocked
and you're like wait i don't want to get
mocked let me not do this right right
and so it's like
um but yeah all the folk when all the
focus is on short term from the top it
trickles all the way down to your
employees and
just everything goes wrong totally agree
with you man i guess i'm agreeing on
this podcast yeah we have a lot of
agreement
not enough disagreeing not enough
disagreeing well we're going to have to
do another one
where we can find some things we
disagree on for sure um
yeah you so you don't sell a course i do
not sell a course never have
pressure to sell a course i mean i find
that everyone wants to
get everyone to sell a course now you
dirty dirty bastard
i ha i i've been i've been sick i've
been suggested
by by people to sell a course really
yes i have i have well of course
as well as so
when i was doing that sort of business
documentary series
graham recommended uh an additional
way to monetize our show
whatever yeah he i mean he was throwing
around some numbers that he
was seeing from other people in his
niche from doing seminars making tons of
money be like look dude you can make
stupid money 700 bucks ahead and you
could pack this place with
a thousand people 2 000 people
and is that
a a great opportunity is that a great
capitalistic
opportunity to make more money and yeah
of course it is it's a great i mean
that's a that's a way to look at things
but i just couldn't i
can't i don't know what it is
why it seems so unattractive to me
to do something like that when because
it just i feel like it just taints the
art because that whole thing was like
like you said it was an art project to
me and when i when i
try to try to throw in something
that just sells
people an opportunity to listen to some
guy ramble for an hour
yeah it takes everything for me it makes
me just feel
i just feel gross i don't know how else
to say it here's why and
i think you instinctually feel what is
actually true
about what you're what that offering is
you're not giving people there's money
their their money's worth there's like
no way that that's actually worth
seven hundred dollars ahead for them to
as you say watch a guy ramp like what
what is this
so you're obsessed with creating
value we might say for you know your
listener and more value than they're
ultimately having to pay
at the door there is this mentality of
like
just take what you can get sort of from
people
that i think is so toxic right now
and it's because they don't know who
their buyers are it's that's what i find
is like a lot of these people have not
encountered
their course buyers they only pay
attention to their successes they don't
pay attention to the losers they sue the
losers
for complaining and so it's really sad
to me i think a lot of people don't see
the cost of what they're doing
and that's something i'm trying to shine
a light on but yeah i think you are just
feeling something instinctually that is
just
sort of obvious which is it's not a good
deal for the people
that you're building up an audience of
you're selling your audience out
and it's like it's one thing to sell
them out in a way
that gives them something that like is
like pretty obviously negotiably
equipped like selling a mug right okay
you're spending ten dollars you get a
mug
mug's worth about ten dollar whatever
that's fine
but when you're trying to get seven
hundred dollars squeeze it out of people
really
crank the toothpaste tube for all it's
worth
that's when you get into this weird
world where you and i
the people we're kind of architecturing
something where we
know it's not ethical we're we like we
know in the back of our mind that it's
not a good buy
so why are we selling it if a lot of
these people are selling courses they
would never buy themselves
that's what blows my mind they would
never buy it so why would you sell it
especially because i've been a victim of
it i know what it's like
really you bought it you bought some
well i was i was telling you about the
the pyramids the pyramids i was a part
of when i was like 17 years old
worse of course yeah you know what you
don't want to do that to somebody you
don't want to be the death of innocence
for somebody
you know those who what was it
what is it those who have you heard you
know what i'm talking talking about i
forget can i do teach
yes those who cannot do teach yeah let
me [ __ ] look up that goddamn quote i
gotta find out what it is
it's those who cannot do teach if you
see someone trying to teach something
you immediately become
suspicious of okay why are you charging
money to teach people how to do this
instead of doing it yourself
right if you knew so much about stock
trading why are you charging someone to
teach them like why don't you just go do
it and make a bunch of money yeah
well 100 that's the question they can
never answer they'll go spin off about
you know well it's because i just care
about people so much
yeah right you care about somebody yeah
that's why you're charging them two
thousand dollars
because that's how much you care about
them but then again dude
then again i have to say i would totally
spend 2 000 bucks to go
sit at a tony robbins seminar i think
that would be pretty cool i've always
wanted to do that
sure yeah like tony robbins is one of
those weird edge cases where it's like
he's so much at the top of his game and
it's almost like a different experience
because he's not really even selling you
information he's sort of selling you
himself
it's like it's like experience a unique
human who you will rarely
see and it's almost like a performance
not even a
you know uh yeah it's not about
information it's really about like
you're just
going to see tony robbins you could be
told that it's the exact same
information but no tony robbins and
it's like going to the super bowl a
hundred percent it's an event
and uh tony robbin he more teaches like
he doesn't
normally i mean from what i've seen
teach how to get rich he's more teaching
be inspired be whatever and that is one
of those things that if that's what you
want to like
do i don't really care because how can
you measure the failure of a the
inspired speech
you really can't but you can measure the
success or failure
of a get rich quick and that's the whole
thing is these people aren't delivering
so tony robbins if he's telling you he's
gonna make you inspired he probably will
make you inspired
i don't know dude i was listening i was
listening to a uh sometimes in the
morning if i'm like
if i'm just not feeling it i'll put on
his [ __ ] uh tony robbins
hour of power and i'll just like listen
to him in the background just ramble
and it just gets me fired up sometimes
like it gets me
it just gets me energized and wanting to
get [ __ ] done
and sometimes you need that sometimes
you need it it's fine it's fine like
the funny thing though is there's so
many free things out there
that the idea of buying some of these
courses to me is almost funny because
it's like
you guys know we have like zig ziglar we
have all these famous guys
who did this and now a lot of them are
dead a lot of their stuff is just
free online go do that
before you join somebody's course right
like yeah but instead it's the
shiny thing it's the the marketing is
what ends up selling it and it's a
marketing that
the main message is like you can be a
millionaire by the time you're 20
you know in your 20s you can be some big
shot
retire on a beach somewhere whatever
yeah and it's like they're really
selling
they're not selling a info product
they're selling a dream
i call them dream salesman that's what
their actual job is
they take your dream and they sell it
back to you
and that's what turns the tickets it's
not the idea that i've always died
you know i really wanted to work for
jeff bezos it's that i
always wanted to live on a beach
somewhere and you're telling me i can
and it's easier than i thought and if i
just follow you the expert
you're going to teach me how to do it
those are the people that i call out